one of my kind of like secret smaller
resolutions was that I really wanted to
make an effort in my wardrobe and the
first item I bought up 2019 for myself
clothing wise was this red sweatshirt do
I have a plain red sweatshirt very
similar to this in my wardrobe already a
hell yeah but a so said [ __ ] it whatever
the [ __ ] you want who cares
and that's another resolution of mine
for 2019 so technically they cancel each
other out and I'm not doing good or bad
no no no you know your life is different
now welcome to a cooking video I woke up
this morning and that was craving matzo
ball soup to be fair I've been craving
matzo ball soup since the end of 2018
every stuffers day every morning that's
a lie and I never lie to you
you look great but like the last two
months of last year I kept waking that
ball like every other day at crappy
matzo ball soup thinking maybe I'll make
it today and I never did and this
morning you know what I've craved it I
said I have a car and knives in my house
so let's go get ingredients and let's
make it and then I decided let's film it
because I would have filmed things that
I genuinely enjoyed doing this year one
of them made my voice cracked like a boy
going through puberty which is also the
inspiration from dressed today I would
have filmed things that I generally
enjoy doing and I was gonna make this
for myself anyway today so may as well
bring you along for the ride I've never
made matzo ball soup before I'm already
at a disadvantage because I couldn't
find matzo meal which is part of the
recipe but art the Stewart on line said
that I can crush up some crackers and
that's kind of the same thing so always
trust someone that's been to jail let's
just jump right names I have a feeling
this is gonna take longer than I
anticipated I will slowly decrease in my
enthusiasm for this activity throughout
this video
oh don't pinch us to look for a recipe
and I found one on budget bites calm
I'll link it down below know what in
classic grace fashion I haven't fully
read through this recipe at all it says
it only takes an hour and a half which
already feels like a lot this year you
know we say yes to the dress and the
stress want to digest some matzo balls
of me hey digestion balls let's do it I
didn't do any meal prep [ __ ] me first
thing starts we need two minced garlic
through closed
garlic but just [ __ ] already has minced
garlic hell yeah
it's a do submit prep I need to dice one
yellow onion the funny thing or maybe
this is not funny is that people have
trouble with onions and like tearing up
when they cut them I hardly ever do and
I think it's because um I don't have
feelings okay now we need three stalks
of celery what do they sell celery in
this amount
no one ever needs this amount of celery
and maybe three stalks max unless you
own a Bloody Mary bar sorry I'm really
taking it to the celery industry in 2019
not holding back I'm choosing the
important things to get upset at this
year did it okay and we need three
carrots I really should have done this
off-camera appealing actually I'm just
gonna do this off camera okay so we have
our onions carrots celery and garlic
they're gonna put 1 tablespoon of
vegetable oil or canola oil in a big ol
pot on the stove oh that's too much I
think that's too much hold on and saute
all of them until the onions are soft
and transparent and or you know five
minutes generally okay so that pots
still going right now has a couple more
minutes and the next step says to add
chicken breasts and then chicken broth
in water and dill is a mixture but
doesn't say to cook the chicken breasts
and I'm pretty sure not supposed to add
raw chicken breasts to this so I'm gonna
just cook it cuz I'm scared what a dupe
thing to do beginning of 2019 give
yourself salmonella I mean I already
Ruth would mess up at the end of 2018 I
want to leave that self-harm last year
oh well my timing is all off now okay so
this is what happens when I feel
overwhelmed with multitasking my hands
completely eco paralyzed and stop kqj
chickens pretty cooked now gonna have
chicken six cups of chicken broth two
cups of water and some cracked pepper
and a couple sprigs of dill and then
we're gonna bring that to a boil and
when it reaches a boil we're gonna let
it simmer for 30 minutes that was a
mouthful I think that's the correct
stuff that we're doing this looks dirty
it's not it's just water marks okay
don't judge me okay okay
that's all calm down and just take a
second apply before we move on to the
next step okay I just need everyone calm
down
everyone's calm we're having fun you
know how I told you that I didn't have
matzo meal um turns out I did in my
cabinet and I realized this has been the
inspiration for why I've been wanting to
make matzo ball soup for so long because
you're on grace
I guess ordered this on Amazon one night
when she wanted matzo ball soup and it's
been in my cabinet for months how I
didn't remember that was in there I
don't know doesn't matter
we have matzo meal I don't need a grind
up crackers sorry mrs. Stewart usually
make the matzo ball dough in a medium
bowl we're gonna whisk together three
large eggs and three tablespoons of
vegetable oil and 2a could be eggs ah
great stop [ __ ] shelling here get out
you can't hide like a kid that got into
a club underage yes then we're gonna add
our matzo meal or matzo meal
I don't know generally anything about
anything but teaspoon of salt half a
teaspoon of baking powder
please Oh God is that good luck my left
shoulder right dur until it's well
combined well it looks like that oh
that's like oatmeal or some sort of
yeast infection you add three
tablespoons of water and stir until
smooth again then it says refrigerate
for 30 minutes to allow the moxa meal to
absorb the liquid which is great because
our soup is now boiling and we're gonna
turn it down to a simmer for 30 minutes
timing isn't working out 20:19 kicking
the tank now it's at a timer I'm gonna
use Siri I never used Siri Siri set a
timer for 30 minutes setting the timer
okay your timer is set for 30 minutes oh
my god a [ __ ] murdering 20:19 okay so
our timer is almost up but I was reading
more of the recipe which is apparently
something you should do and you're
following the recipe it's like really
read it probably read all of it before
you start cooking and it said when the
soup is done so we're going to take the
chicken out and shred it and then return
it to the simmering soup and I try to do
that to the best of my ability maybe I
was supposed to put raw chicken in there
okay how much longer do we have we have
a whole minute
on our timer right now which you know I
don't know if you're familiar with
previous cooking videos that I've done
but there's only one thing to really do
[Music]
we form it into ping-pong sized balls
and then we put it in the simmering soup
and then we let it simmer for another 20
minutes I guess we'd take it out oh okay
maybe this should have sat longer I
don't know if the ratio is right I feel
like this is gonna fall apart this seems
way too loose should I let this absorb
the mixture for a little bit more unless
this is how it's supposed to be do you
have a photo oh God
touch my laptop with the girl's hand
like this seems a little runny [ __ ] it
we're gonna try it don't think this is
right there was a recipe for the mounts
on the side of the box and I ignored it
and went with this maybe this is wrong
who knows god damn it they're just like
you know abstract balls what a girl says
to try to be polite I have low
expectations is my whole 2019 mantra by
the way oh no they're getting together
I'm touching each other guys it's going
bad it's going really bad down around
look that simmer for 20 minutes who the
[ __ ] knows what's gonna come out of that
it's not so much gonna be matzo ball
soup as is gonna
be just like gross damn it I really
wanted this to work so the recipe on the
side of the matzo ball box is a entirely
different than maybe should have gone
with what's on the box for risk takers
high risk no rewards there's only couple
minutes left on the timer for this soup
and it looks [ __ ] crazy bummer
because this whole idea was just I
wanted matzo balls and the soup was just
the catalyst to get me the matzo ball so
there's two packs in this matzo ball mix
and so I have put together the second
pack just out of pure evil for myself
using what they told me to do on the Box
only two eggs and 1/4 cup of vegetable
oil and let it sit for 15 minutes I'm
gonna do that and then in a giant pot
boil a bunch of water and then make the
matzo balls with your hand and boil them
in the water for 30 minutes I mean the
process of doing this is boiling I made
this it's been sitting for a little bit
I might just take out deep really
horrific-looking matzo balls hoping the
soup and then work on these just cuz I
really want this to work another ring
this together I don't want to fail I
also just want to eat decent matzo
that's what we are right now okay a
quick update I pulled that one of the
you know seemingly horrific looking
matzo and I just tried it and it's
pretty good maybe this is just another
reminder that you shouldn't judge people
by their appearances I about people
should be respecting that moral code I
still I'm gonna try and make the second
batch of matzah good don't judge a book
by it's cover eat it out first eat it
first holy [ __ ] that was infinitely
easier when you mix them with wet hands
and they actually look like matzo balls
that's a matzo ball there there's
something there learn from your mistakes
okay then we're supposed to reduce the
heat to a simmer cover and cook for 30
minutes wait later now I'm sweaty I just
took my dog for a walk this is taking
longer than expected but we expected
that so it's just taken time i boiled
them for about 20 minutes and then i
took out from the soup some of the
unique
looking matzo balls to make room for the
second batch of matzo balls and let them
boil in there for the last 10 minutes I
left and you know some of the quirky
weinzheimer is on the septum we're gonna
pour ourselves some [ __ ] soup because
[ __ ] we wanted this and we're doing it
and you know what we didn't stop we
didn't give up we didn't need to do this
you probably could have gone and found a
restaurant that delivered and gave us
the matzo ball soup but no nineteen
twenty eighteen nineteen twenty nineteen
here we go let's see how it looks oh my
god oh my god oh wow oh it's hot wow
this is like a Campbell's soup
commercial aren't those commercials all
about like how it's winter and like
dad's gone so just give the kids soup
you okay so this was some of our first
batch of matzo and this was our second
batch so proof that there's growth
everywhere give up try again whoa eat
[ __ ] Martha Stewart I'm like really
proud of myself
and I also know that this video doesn't
appeal to a lot of people because I
don't know that there's many teens out
there watching this video that also
crave matzo ball soup enough to make it
on their own but if you want to just
mark off you know like four hours on an
afternoon
okay I'm gonna taste it now even though
it's hot as [ __ ] I made this joke before
but if you ever wonder what I look like
giving a [ __ ]
alright oh that's even too gross for me
Noah he's a finger food yes okay that's
it for this matzo ball soup making
journey I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did give this video a thumbs up and
don´t get describe to this youtube
channel because this year we just have a
[ __ ] fun what we used to do the
Buckley's back on YouTube I just texted
in then maybe 2019 is to return to the
sweet wonderful fun flying by the seat
of our pants 2007 ish era of YouTube and
I truly hope so this is a video where I
made soup get me that's pretty [ __ ]
exciting so hit the bell notification
turn on both on for kitchen how the [ __ ]
you doing all the things that you're
supposed to do that all the other
youtubers that play the game tell you to
do do that for my channel please thank
you
I don't know one of my lenses all right
try I don't know everything is going
okay I'm proud of myself
remember this moment cause it only goes
downhill from here
the rest of the year you know that song
panic at the dik-diks Oh or something